next week dealers and collectors will
gather into 45 in New York which brings
together art and antiques from around
the world one prized item up for sale is
a 500 year old map but is the most
expensive map ever offered on the open
market and it could be yours for ten
million dollars Bloomberg pursuits gems
charm we got a first look at the map and
joins us now first did I get the
concession right of the Art Fair cheap
off yeah very good
describe this map and how it was found I
mean this was in obscurity for a long
time and really just discovered rather
recently it was sitting rolled up in a
castle in Switzerland for centuries and
I mean people knew what it was sort of
but it really only kind of sold for the
first time in the 80s the Library of
Congress when it became aware of it
tried to purchase it failed and then
this English collector had it for on 40
years and now this is the first time
that it's actually ever really come onto
the open market okay so what is it
depict so it depicts the known world as
it was known in 1531 so it's on vellum
so it's on five or six goat skins and
that's actually why the color is still
so vivid because it was actually inked
in and stayed there and so a lot of what
it depicts is I mean Africa is fairly
faithful Europe as you can imagine is
also fairly faithful because this was
done by a cartographer in Italy but the
eastern seaboard had really only been
explored ten years before so they sort
of imagined the eastern seaboard as
being this kind of narrow sliver of land
on the other side of which was the
Pacific Ocean so there's a kind of
smiling man it had turban around two
miles in North Carolina but it's it's
really fascinating to see these people's
ideas of what the world was like well
talk about who may be interested in
buying this map in a moment but going
back those many hundreds of years who
would have owned something like this who
was buying cartography like this back
then Kings you know a lot of the time in
the cartography that we actually see
that survived is not only used for
exploration and actual navigation but
also for treaties and for negotiation
between various heads of state as they
tried to kind of
figure out what belonging to whom it's a
it's a big thing I mean this this
physically is a large object yeah you
mentioned the velum what does it look
like it this it's something that you
could spend a lot of time studying yeah
you absolutely can it's over six feet
long over three and a half feet high
it's put in this ival frame but it set
it kind of meant to float but really
it's actually designed to be set on a
table so that people can walk around and
look at it it's not actually intended as
decoration so there's kind of lettering
and fonts that go in multiple directions
and gorgeous illustration really
stunning colors that there's liquid gold
that's been painted all over it
it's really beautiful you mentioned it
in the past the Library of Congress has
tried to buy it what do we know broadly
speaking of who where what institutions
might be interested in owning this there
I imagine are people who collect maps in
specific yeah very very wealthy people
as Daniel crouch the man who is actually
selling this a rare book dealer who has
locations in New York and London said to
me when you get to seven figures the air
gets pretty thin but you know there are
definitely institutions who would like
to purchase it with funds that they
raise from other people you know the
Library of Congress actually bought the
other most expensive map in the world
which is the Valda Mueller map which the
first map that actually shows America
through the words America and they
bought that in 2003 for ten million
dollars but it was never open on the
open market or anything so yeah the
Library of Congress maybe some very very
wealthy donors who knows will say